derek shovin's trial is being used as a
lesson for some teenagers we visited
mount vernon high school outside of new
york city
to see how students are reacting
especially to the hard to watch video of
george floyd
being arrested what kind of a feeling
happens to you
when you see it displayed and played
over so often
i just feel sad about it because like
their family have to like
like relive the moment all this time
and it's it gets me angry sometimes that
there's still not justice but let's hope
there's justice
what does justice look like for you i
feel like he should like
go to jail you would be relieved if he
is
guilty if he's found guilty because um
it would show up um it would show that
there's hope
that police officers can actually be
punished for what they
if they do something wrong they will
actually be punished for it it would
show there's hope for us
of course mr schoen's lawyers argue he
acted reasonably and drug use and
medical conditions contributed to george
floyd's death
they claim the state has failed to prove
its case beyond a reasonable doubt
i love doing these stories for our show
where you talk to young people
they i always learn something one of the
things that i heard expressed over and
over yesterday from these young people
compassion
for derek shelvin derek shovin's family
yeah a lot of them many of them said you
know they believe he made a mistake
they believe that he should be found
guilty that's how they feel but they
think it was a mistake
and they expressed compassion for his
family and his loved ones yeah
one of the poignant details of the trial
is the fact that there is a chair set
aside for a single family member from
both the floyd family and the showman
family and the floyd chair has been or
the shoving chair has been largely empty
yeah but i also think about the fact
that on the floyd side felonious floyd
in particular has had to be there in
that courtroom as they air again and
again the worst moments of his family's
life and the courage that takes
the the students uh did express that
concern watching it over and over a lot
of them said they couldn't actually
watch it
all the way through um shout out to mrs
delaport
miss delaport and miss manson's class
the students i've done stories like this
where we've
talked about you know school shootings
with kids i always learned something
yeah
it's great that they're using it as as
we saw as a teachable moment but yeah
it's important that they're watching it
really is